bomb attack on the western jet fall
Center was truly appalling I'm sure the
whole house will condemn it in the
strongest possible terms and I Echo the
home secretary's tribute to the
emergency services and Border force
staff who responded but I must ask her
can she tell me whether counter-terror
police and counter-extremism units are
involved in the investigation it doesn't
make sense for them not to be why are
they not
turning to the Dreadful conditions at
manston four thousand people are now on
a site designed to accommodate 1600
people with some families there for
weeks conditions that have been
described as inhumane with risks of fire
disorder and infection there are
confirmed dip Theory outfit outbreaks
reports of Scabies and MRSA outbreaks
also reports of outbreaks of violence
and untrained staff she said nothing
about what she was doing to address
those immediate Public Health crises and
also the issues for untrained staff
Behind These are deeper failures in the
government's policies on Asylum and
channel Crossings decision making has
collapsed the home office took just 14
000 initial Asylum decisions in the last
12 months compared to 28 000 six years
ago 96 percent of the small boat
arrivals last year have still not had a
decision and initial decisions alone are
taking more than 400 Days on this
conservative government's watch can she
confirm that the nationality's borders
Bill and changes to immigration rules
have in fact added further bureaucracy
and delays leading to tens of thousands
more people waiting in Asylum
accommodation and more than a hundred
million pounds extra on Asylum
accommodation bills because their
policies are pushing up the use of
hotels and the increase in delays
there's also been a total failure to
protect to prevent a huge proliferation
of gangs in the channel why has the Home
Secretary refused our calls for a major
New National Crime agency unit with
hundreds of additional specialist
officers to work with europol and others
to crack down on the gangs as well as
the Urgent work needed with France to
get a proper agreement in place and can
she also confirm on the Rwanda plan that
she has spent an extra 20 million pounds
on top of the hundred and 20 million
pounds already spent on a policy that
she has herself described as failing and
that her officials have described as
unenforceable and with a high risk of
Fraud and isn't it now time to drop this
unethical and unworkable scheme and put
the money into tackling the backlogs and
tackling the criminal gangs
and let me ask her about her own
decisions which are very there are very
serious allegations now being reported
that the Home Secretary was warned by
officials and other ministers she was
acting outside the law by failing to
provide alternative accommodation
can she confirm that she turned down
plans contingency plans that she was
offered that would have reduced
overcrowding as the reports say there
are also legal obligations including
under the 1999 Act and the 2018
regulations can she confirm she was
advised repeatedly that she was breaking
the law by failing to agree to these
plans one of these meetings on manston
was on the 19th of October can she
confirm she refused these proposals on
that date it was the same day that she
broke sections 2.3 and sections 1.4 of
the ministerial code so can she confirm
or can she tell us whether in fact she
breached the ministerial code which
provides for ministers abiding by the
law did she breach the ministerial code
three times in a single day and how is
anyone supposed to have confidence in
her as a Home Secretary with these
serious issues she referred in her
statement to Security checks these are
very important but her statement his
disregard is undermined by her own
disregard for security her letter today
says makes clear that the incident over
which she resigned was not a one-off and
rather and contrary to her previous
claims to have reported the breach
rapidly as soon as she realized she
instead had to be challenged several
times by one of her colleagues she has
also not answered the crucial questions
about security breaches while she was
attorney general can she tell us whether
she was involved in a leap to the
telegraph reported in the telegraph on
the 21st of January about information
about attorney general action on a case
involving the security service has she
sent any other government documents by
WhatsApp telegram or other social media
and given that it's been less than a
week since she was reappointed and less
than a fortnight since she was first
forced to resign for breaching the
ministerial code and every day since her
appointment there have been more stories
about possible security or ministerial
code breaches how is anybody supposed to
have confidence in her given the serious
responsibilities of the Home Secretary
to stand up for our national security
for security standards and for Public
Safety the Prime Minister promised that
this would be a government of Integrity
of professionalism and of accountability
isn't the Home Secretary letting
everyone down and failing on all of
these countries